what if you were swallowed by a whale  well the first thing you'd have to worry  about is getting shredded to pieces by  the whale's massive teeth that are as  big as a chef's knife now if you  survived that then you'd descend down  the throat here you'd experience  disgusting smells and hydrochloric acid  eating up your skin next you'd be  dropped into the first and largest of  the whale's four stomachs  you might see some bioluminescent squid  while you're in here and you'd better  enjoy this brief light show because  before you know it you'd be tossed from  one stomach to the next with the whale  stomach acids slowly breaking down your  body you'd just become a pile of bones  and then be pooped out by the whale so  have you ever wondered